schönen guten morgen
es freut mich ihnen heute den pcr test
und labor bus des amts für rüstung und
wehrtechnik vorstellen zu können wir
haben hier die möglichkeit
maschinell unterstützt bis zu 1000 tests
pro tag durchführen zu können wir
konnten uns heute eine weitere fähigkeit
des österreichischen bundesheeres
anschauen die im bund einzigartig ist
nämlich einen bus der ein mobiles labor
auch beinhaltet um die testungen
durchzuführen nicht nur im zusammenhang
mit dem corona virus es gibt ja immer
wieder auch die notwendigkeit dies auch
bei anderen bakterien viren zu tun
geländegängig dort wo die einsätze auch
stattfinden wir sind unglaublich stolz
auf unsere mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter die soldatinnen und soldaten
die ihre arbeit beim amt für rüstungs
und wehrtechnik so großartig machen in
den 18 monaten waren dass
hunderttausende
arbeitsschritte und zig tausend
arbeitsstunden geleistet worden sind zur
sicherheit der österreicherinnen und
österreicher